digamos que tenemos la integral
indefinida de la raíz de 6x - x cuadrada
menos 5 y está pues como se ve no es una
integral inmediata ni tengo a la mano la
derivada de esta expresión así que no
puedo hacer una sustitución directamente
y tendremos que ser ingeniosos para
resolverlo como lo sugiere el nombre del
vídeo e intentaremos una sustitución
trigonométricas pero esta expresión
tampoco se parece a las sustituciones
trigonométricas que estamos
acostumbrados que tienen la forma
1 - x cuadrada o x cuadrada menos 1 x
cuadrado + 1 la expresión que tenemos
tiene un radical tiene algo con x al
cuadrado más o menos se parece pero
veamos que podemos hacer para
convertirla en una expresión que tenga
la forma de las que conocemos
ahora déjame borrar todo esto que tengo
aquí y vamos a regresar a nuestra
expresión y vamos a ver si es posible
completar el cuadrado aquí recordarás
que completar cuadrados lo hemos hecho
ya en diversos vídeos y esto lo voy a
escribir como
como menos 5 - y déjame escribirlo así x
cuadrada menos 6 x bueno aquí afuera
tengo 6 x positivo pero menos menos me
da más y ahora quiero que esto sea un
cuadrado perfecto o sea que el número
tengo que encontrar que cuando lo sumo a
sí mismo me da menos 6 pues será el
menos 3 y al elevarlo al cuadrado me da
9 así que es menos 3 y al cuadrado pues
lo tengo que escribir como 9 pero veamos
no puedo sumar arbitrariamente un 9 aquí
bueno de hecho no lo sume de lorre este
porque aquí hay un menos y aquí hay un
más
este es un -9
entonces para neutralizar este -9 que
está aquí tengo que sumar un 9 entonces
aquí sumó 9 el claro por la cábala de x
y todo esto tiene sentido porque veamos
si yo multiplico este menos que está
aquí afuera pues voy a obtener el menos
x cuadrada el menos x menos 6 x me da 6
x positivo que es lo que tengo aquí y
luego tengo un -9 que se cancela con
este más 9 que está acá y regreso a la
expresión original
si yo agrego un -9 y un +9 pues estoy
agregando un 0 que no hace nada bueno
esto de acá se simplifica en un 4 y esta
expresión que está aquí se convierte en
x menos 3 al cuadrado
me integral indefinida ahora se verá así
claro todo lo que he hecho solo es
manipulación algebraica
y ahora será la integral indefinida de
la raíz de 4 menos x menos 3 al cuadrado
de x y observamos que empieza a tomar
una forma de las que me gustan de la que
estoy buscando bueno ahora necesitamos
trabajar porque quiero un 1 aquí
entonces vamos a factorizar el 4 aquí
afuera y entonces esto será igual a ésta
será la integral voy a poner un radical
aquí de 4 veces
de 4 que está multiplicando a 1 - x 3 al
cuadrado sobre cuatro de x y podemos ver
que esto cada vez se parece más a la
forma que estoy buscando a ver vamos a
simplificar un poco más esta expresión y
ahora pues puedo sacar el 4 de la raíz y
lo pongo como la integral de dos veces
la raíz de 1 - a ver mejor voy a
reescribir esto no que sea
1 - x menos 3 dividido entre 2 todo al
cuadrado de x me dirás de dónde saqué
este 2 bueno es nada mas elevándolo al
cuadrado o sea si yo elevó x menos 3 al
cuadrado tengo el término de arriba y 2
al cuadrado es el numerador que yo tenía
pero la que está de este lado se parece
a una de las formas que yo conozco
recordemos en otros vídeos hemos
mencionado que coseno cuadrado de teta
es igual a 1 menos seno cuadrado de teta
pero miren esto estas dos expresiones se
ven exactamente igual y más aún si yo
dijera que esto que está aquí es
exactamente igual a seno cuadrado de
teta
y bueno ahora hagamos la sustitución si
está digamos que x menos tres entre dos
al cuadrado ahora será igual hacen o
cuadrado de teta
tomemos ahora la raíz cuadrada en ambos
lados y entonces esto quedará como x 3
entre 2
es igual al seno de teta
eventualmente esto desaparecerá y
tendremos que resolver todo en términos
de teta así que vamos a hacerlo vamos a
ver quién éste está en términos de x y
para poner a theta en términos de x pues
tomamos el arco seno de ambos lados y si
claro este lado el arco seno del seno
del pp simplemente teta y nos va a
quedar que teta es igualar coseno de x
menos 3 entre 2 suficiente hasta aquí
ahora también tendremos que ver quién es
de x en términos de teta así que vamos a
hacerlo y entonces ahora veamos si yo
multiplico ambos lados de la ecuación
por 2 voy a obtener que x menos 3 es
igual a dos veces el seno de eta por lo
que x es igual a 2 seno de teta más 3 y
ahora tomamos la derivada con respecto
al dt en ambos lados y me queda de x en
de teta es igual a dos veces el coste no
detecta la derivada de tres pues es cero
y ahora multiplicando de teta
tengo que de x es igualdad 2 coseno de
teta de teta y ahora estamos listos para
hacer la sustitución en nuestra integral
indefinida
en nuestra integral se verá así la
integral indefinida de dos veces la raíz
de uno menos
seno cuadrado de teta de x
pero de x es igual a 2 josé no de teta
de teta
entonces aquí escribo 2 coseno de teta
del theta ii sigamos simplificando
entonces este término que tengo aquí es
simplemente coseno cuadrado de teta y
aquí estamos tomando la raíz cuadrada de
coseno cuadrado de teta
sí o sea todo esto que está aquí va a
ser la raíz de coseno cuadrado de teta
que es simplemente coseno de t está
nuestra integral ahora se ve como esto
esto será la integral indefinida de dos
veces la raíz de coseno cuadrado de teta
que ya dijimos que es coseno de teta por
dos coseno detecta si lo que está aquí
este término es exactamente el que está
aquí y todo este radical se simplificó
en esta expresión o sea teníamos la raíz
de uno menos seno cuadrado de teta que
fue concentrado de teta y se simplificó
nada más en esto que está aquí
detecta y entonces todo esto se
convierte cuatro veces el coseno
cuadrado de teta de teta
tenemos ahora está pero la verdad
tampoco es una integral muy fácil de
resolver no es inmediata no puedo hacer
sustitución o directamente entonces qué
es lo que vamos a hacer así que una vez
más tendremos que regresar a las
identidades trigonométricas bueno a ver
si recuerdas esta y si no está siempre
en los libros de trigonometría y los de
cálculo es una identidad muy conocida en
la que dice que coseno cuadrado de teta
es igual a un medio de uno más el coseno
de dos teta
esta la he demostrado ya en otros vídeos
hagamos la sustitución entonces esta
integral va a ser ahora
la integral de 4 veces
un medio
de uno más el coseno de dos tetas
detesta
y esto empieza a verse bien
y se simplifica en bueno 4 por un medio
esto es 12 y entonces esto lo vamos a
reescribir como la integral de 2 más 2
coseno de 2 teta
todo esto de teta esta es una integral
pues ya muy directa a ver veamos qué es
esto que está aquí pues es la derivada
con respecto a teta del coseno de no no
no es no es la derivada con respecto a
teta de seno de dos teta y es lo que
está aquí o sea tomando la derivada de
lo que está afuera que es el coseno de
dos teta y lo multiplicamos por la
derivada de lo que está dentro que es el
2 entonces tenemos esto que está aquí
el anti derivada de lo que está aquí ya
sabe el 2 pues va a ser simplemente 2
teta
y entonces vayamos reescribiendo
entonces tenemos el 2 teta más el seno
de dos tetas
pues más una constante pero no podemos
olvidar que nuestro problema inicial
está en términos de x no detecta a osea
ahora tendremos que hacer una nueva
sustitución regresar nuestra expresión
todo en términos de x si observemos lo
que teníamos
vamos a escribirlo aquí al ladito o sea
theta es igual al arco seno de x 3 entre
2 y veamos si ahora yo hiciera la
sustitución de esto que está aquí
directamente o sea poner dos veces el
arco seno de x menos 3 entre 2 más el
seno de 2 veces el arco seno de x menos
3 sobre 2 bueno eso sería correcto eso
podemos hacerlo pero no es una solución
muy bonita muy elegante digamos o sea si
tomo el seno del arco seno pues esto
nada más se va a simplificar a x menos 3
entre 2
voy a tratar de aclarar mis ideas yo
quiero escribir esto en términos de
theta o sea escribir el seno de teta
es igual al seno del arco seno de x 3
sobre 2
y esto se simplifica a x 3 sobre 2 y si
yo pudiera escribir esto en términos de
seno de teta entonces las cosas se
simplificarían mucho y vamos a ver si
podemos hacerlo pero tendremos que
utilizar otra identidad que no sé si la
tengas en mente ahorita si las recuerdas
yo ya la probé en otro vídeo y es la que
me dice que el seno de 2 teta que es
igual al seno de eta más teta si voy a
escribir seno de teta mastretta está es
igual al seno de t tacos seno de teta
más el seno de teta
más el coche no detecta que todo se
simplifica en dos veces el seno de teta
coseno detectan algunas personas
memorizan esto para los exámenes o sea
que si pronto tienes un examen de
trigonometría p sería buena idea
recordarlo pero continuemos ahora no
está integral en términos de teta la
vamos a reescribir como dos tetas más
dos veces el seno de teta coseno de teta
más c
y yo quisiera seguir escribiendo esto en
términos solo del seno de teta así que
veamos que podemos hacer con este coche
no detecta que tenemos aquí y recordemos
en que coseno cuadrado de teta es igual
a 1 menos seno cuadrado de teta de lo
que puedo decir que el coche no de teta
es igual a la raíz de uno menos el seno
cuadrado de teta pudiera parecer que nos
estamos complicando mucho pero lo
importante es expresar esto nada más en
términos de seno de teta así que no está
anti derivada ahora la vamos a escribir
como dos tetas más dos veces el seno de
teta por el coseno de teta que es esto
que está aquí que es la raíz de uno
menos seno cuadrado de teta más c
y ahora pues continuemos si recuerdas el
seno de teta es igual a x menos 3 entre
2 entonces ahora hagamos esta
sustitución
y esto que tenemos aquí es 2 teta y
entonces va a ser dos veces declaró no
nos podemos escapar del arco seno
entonces es dos veces el arco seno de x
menos tres entre dos
más y ahora más y ahora vamos a cambiar
colores entonces tenemos más dos veces
el seno de teta y esto es igual a dos
veces
x menos 3 entre 2 pues eso es seno de
teta
y todo eso por la raíz de 1 - es el
cuadrado de teta pero quienes seno
cuadrado de teta pues es x menos 3 sobre
2 al cuadrado
y yo obviamente pues más la constante
vamos a ver si podemos simplificar aún
más esto vamos a ver entonces tenemos
dos veces el arco seno de x 3 entre 2
más aquí estos dos se cancelan es que
simplemente me queda x menos 3 x la raíz
de haber a mí me gustaría poder
describir esto de otra manera a ver si
fuera la raíz de vamos a ponerlo así uno
menos x menos 3 al cuadrado sobre 4 si
que sea x menos 3 al cuadrado sobre 4 la
verdad esta simplificación me está
tomando mucho más de lo que me imaginaba
pero bueno vamos a seguir trabajando a
mí lo que me gustaría ahora es
reescribir esto que está aquí como
y entonces a esto que está aquí afuera
me gustaría multiplicarlo por todos y
dividirlo si no voy a multiplicar y
dividir por dos si entre dos entre dos y
dirás oye por qué estás haciendo esto y
es que lo que quiero es reescribir lo de
esta manera osea veamos esto va a ser
dos veces el arco seno de x menos 3
entre 2 y ahora voy a reorganizar este
este denominador que está aquí vamos a
escribirlo como x menos 3 entre 2 si
este 2 que está aquí es el que
corresponde al que había yo puesto de
este lado
y ahora el 2 lo voy a reescribir como la
raíz de 4 o sea que será la raíz de 4
que multiplica a la raíz de 1 - x menos
3 al cuadrado sobre 4 + c y bueno ya
estoy muy cerca ya que así lo logró
entonces esto lo voy a reescribir como
otra vez dos veces el arco seno de x
menos 3 sobre 2 más
más x menos 3 entre 2 y ahora voy a
meter este 4 a la otra raíz o sea que
esto va a ser la raíz de 4 - x menos 3
al cuadrado más c
y escribiéndolo una vez más tenemos dos
veces el arco seno de x 3 entre 2
más x menos 3 entre 2 y ahora vamos con
el radical este es 4 - x cuadrada menos
vamos a describir lo vamos a
desarrollarlo sería menos x cuadrada
menos 6 x más 9 y esto que está aquí
- menos 6 x 6 x tengo menos equis
cuadrada menos 5 y esto que está aquí es
con lo que habíamos empezado esta es
nuestra anti derivada que habíamos
empezado
y lo que tenemos es dos veces el arco
seno de x 3 entre 2
más x menos tres entre dos más este
radical que es 6x - x cuadrado menos 5 y
todo todo esto que está aquí es nuestra
anti derivada original de lo que tenemos
aquí arriba
si a los que teníamos aquí
si a lo que teníamos aquí que es la anti
derivada de la raíz de 6 x x cuadrado
menos 5 de x
yo creo que ésta es igual de cansado que
yo la verdad mi mano ya no aguanta este
problema para nada es fácil qué bueno
terminamos
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo